With Mission: Impossible Rogue Nation out
now, let’s take a look at 7 things you probably
didn’t know about the fifth film in the
super-spy series.
Although Tom Cruise has a good deal of experience
stunt driving, before filming Rogue Nation's
high-speed car and motorbike chases along
winding Moroccan roads, he spent an intensive
six weeks training, working with stunt co-ordinator
Wade Eastwood, whose speciality is car stunts.
Cruise learnt to drift drive and, according
to Eastwood, the actor rode the BMW S1000RR
sport bike at speeds of up to 100 miles per
hour!
When Ethan Hunt dives into an underwater facility
to change a security profile card, the chamber
where he has to swap out the card is labelled
108.
This is an Easter Egg for JJ Abrams' TV series
Lost, where the number 108, or a sequence
of numbers which added up to 108, often appeared.
Rogue Nation is produced by Bad Robot, a production
company founded by Abrams, who also directed
Mission: Impossible 3.
The name of Swedish actress Rebecca Ferguson's
character Ilsa was inspired by a character
of the same name played by another Swedish
actress in a 1940s movie.
That actress was Ingrid Bergman and the movie
was Casablanca, which starred Humphrey Bogart.
By the way, not so coincidentally, part of
Rogue Nation was actually filmed in Casablanca,
Morocco.
During Ferguson's first meeting with director
Chris McQuarrie and Tom Cruise, they compared
Ilsa in Mission: Impossible to Ingrid Bergman
and fellow Swedish actress Greta Garbo in
terms of their grace and the use of light
and shadows in the way they were filmed.
To get ready for some especially dizzying
stunts, Rebecca Ferguson spent over a month
training in pilates, explosive running, fight
technique and firearms for 6 hours a day 6
days a week.
Her training also included numerous 12-foot
practice drops in the stunt rehearsal area
before she tackled the real 75-foot drop from
the roof of the Vienna State Opera House on
her first day of filming!
By the end of the shoot, Ferguson had done
that drop 40 times!
Oh, and by the way, she also had to overcome
her fear of heights and claustrophobia to
bring those stunts to life.
Remember the movie's opening stunt which Tom
Cruise actually did himself, hanging on to
the outside of an Airbus A-400-M military
transport plane as it flew up to 5,000 feet
in the air?
Well, that scene was shot at the RAF Wittering
airbase in Cambridgeshire, England.
A special rig was built to attach the camera
to the outside of the plane and the movie's
cinematographer operated it remotely from
inside the plane.
To capture additional footage from a different
angle, they also filmed from a helicopter
flying beside the plane.
As the airplane was travelling up to 180 miles
per hour, the force of the wind was so great
during filming that Cruise had to have special
contact lenses made to cover his eyeballs
so he could keep his eyes open and still protect
them from engine fumes and airborne debris.
Cruise gave director Christopher McQuarrie
strict instructions not to cut once they started
filming unless he gave a signal to do so by
touching the top of his head!
In the end, Cruise did the stunt a total of
8 times to make sure they got all the shots
they needed.
To make the movie's underwater heist scene
as real as possible, Tom Cruise trained intensively
in free diving, which is basically diving
without breathing apparatus!
Cruise built up to doing a 40-metre free dive
and could actually hold his breath underwater
for around 6 minutes after training in Florida
and the Cayman Islands with veteran athletes
including freediving expert Kirk Krack.
The scene was filmed in a tank measuring about
40 foot square at Leavesden Studios in the
UK.
For added realism, water movers from the Special
Effects department were used in the tank to
make Cruise's hair move and so he could swim
against the current.
However, the force of the moving water was
so strong that they had to tether Cruise to
avoid him getting pushed backwards.
Cruise has said that the dive scene was the
most physically challenging part of the movie
for him, and it took him significantly longer
to recover from than any other scene.
Although shooting a Mission: Impossible action
scene can be pretty intense, Tom Cruise and
Simon Pegg still found time for fun on set
while they were filming a car chase scene
in Casablanca.
The two actors kept themselves amused during
long stretches in the car in the scorching
Moroccan heat by playing pranks, including
sneakily switching on each other's car seat
heater and waiting to see how long it took
the other one to notice!
Now, let me know in the comments below, what
crazy stunts would you like to see Tom Cruise
do next in Mission: Impossible 6?
And which is your favourite Mission: Impossible
movie and why?
If you enjoyed this video, do please share
it, hit the thumbs-up button and subscribe
for more things you didn't know, as well as
movie reviews and interviews.
Thanks for watching!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!